Now, a lot of people
have told me
that they're depressed
about our show getting canceled,
so we thought
we'd cover a subject
that will make you even more
depressed-- the opioid epidemic.
That's right. It's time
for our last Nightly Show
Super Depressing Deep Dive.
Take a look.
♪ ♪
MALE NARRATOR: Hi.
Hey, you good? Not for long.
Welcome
to another Nightly Show
Super Depressing Deep Dive.
Everyone's talking about them.
One of the greatest public
health crises of our time,
the opioid epidemic.
MAN:
An epidemic of drug abuse.
We are seeing more people killed
because of opioid overdose
than traffic accidents.
(tires squealing, static)
NARRATOR:
So how did this happen?
It starts with pain.
-(groaning) -People hate pain,
mainly because it's painful,
and opioids take that pain
and turn it into...
♪ Magic body warmth! ♪
Opioids are any opium-like
compound, like morphine,
invented in 1827
and advertised to children.
Yes, that baby won't cry.
Well, until you take away
its sweet, sweet morphine.
(crying)
In 1898, Bayer tried
to make a less-addictive
morphine called... heroin.
♪ Heroin! ♪
Now, selling legal heroin
may sound crazy,
but this is during the time
when you could get cocaine in
Coca-Cola, and doctors thought
your skull shape determined
how smart you were.
Phrenology.
In the 1970s and '80s,
most doctors avoided opioids
as long-term pain relief
because
of the whole addiction thing.
But in 1995,
Purdue Pharmaceuticals--
sadly not a branch
of Perdue Chicken--
marketed the safest opioid
of all.
♪ Oxycontin! Oxycontin! ♪
And everyone was happy
and pain-free forever. The end.
JK. Pain is life.
It will never go away.
-Like U2 and Guy Fieri.
-(boy shouts)
And hey, it turns out Oxycontin
is crazy addictive,
but to make it seem
mega-awesome, Purdue handed out
branded promotional items,
like fishing hats and CDs.
Yes, that's the title.
It isn't even clever,
like Oxycontin-Eyed Joe!
There were also plush toys,
which we couldn't
find images of,
so we assume
they look like this.
TOY BEAR:
Hug me. I can't feel pain.
(winding down):
I'm a bear...
And to help ease
everyone's fear of addiction,
Purdue created videos
with super trustworthy dudes.
They don't wear out.
They go on working.
They do not have
serious medical side effects.
Thank you kindly,
doctor-type guy
who was totally not paid
to say that.
I bet he was paid to say that.
A year later,
opioid prescriptions
jumped by $11 million.
Those are some Viagra-level
numbers, but without the ads
that make you think
of your parents doing it.
Sales of Oxycontin went
from $44 million in 1996...
MAN:
Triple-decker yacht money!
...to $1.5 billion in 2002.
MEN:
Ya-Ya-Yacht jet!
By 2012, doctors wrote more
than 259 million prescriptions
for opioids--
enough to give a bottle
to every adult in America.
You don't have to be
a chicken scientist
to know that when
everyone's got opioids,
opioid overdoses
are going to skyrocket.
More than 165,000 people
have died of causes
related to painkiller use
since 1999,
including the men who love
to party like it's 1999.
NEWSWOMAN: Tests show
the music icon Prince
died of an opioid overdose.
NARRATOR: That's right, those
greedy drug company bastards
mother(bleep) killed...
Mother(bleep) Prince.
Jesus (bleeping)...
(man grunting à la Prince)
Or... maybe the drug companies
didn't know.
Maybe they were innocent pawns
in this game of chance
we call life.
I'm just playing.
Of course they knew.
The L.A. Times reported
that Purdue marketed Oxycontin
as a 12-hour drug
when they knew
it often only worked for eight,
leading patients
to experience withdrawal
and want higher,
more dangerous doses--
which means we were lied to
by kindly
CD-hat doctor-type guy.
They do not have
serious medical side effects.
What the (bleep), dude?
They hid the evidence
of illegal Oxy rings,
and in 2007,
they lost
a $635 million lawsuit
and three executives pleaded
guilty in misbranding the drug
and downplaying
the risk of addiction.
Even Big Tobacco was like,
"Damn, you guys are scumbags."
That lawsuit
was known years ago,
but we're only addressing
this crisis now. Why?
For the first time
in any first-world country,
the death rate for white,
middle-aged people
is on the rise.
Yep, opioids became
a national epidemic
-because it became a...
-♪ White people problem ♪
♪ Ba, ba, ba, ba. ♪
Hashtag it.
Now hospitals and doctors
feel super bad
about hurting white people,
so they're cracking down
on overprescribing and abuse.
So... is it all better?
-(children cheer)
-Yeah. Wait.
No. Because when addicts
stop getting opioids,
they turn
to the next best thing.
♪ Heroin... ♪
That's right,
our old friend heroin is back.
It's like opioid fast food--
cheap, easy,
and it's colorful mascots
will haunt your nightmares
for eternity.
So now there's a new
white people problem.
The Nantucket Polo Club
is full of heroin addicts.
(horses neighing)
And if that wasn't fun enough,
Big Pharma still makes billions
off our pain
by selling opioids,
and we still don't have
an effective,
non-addictive
chronic pain medication.
Now we just have heroin
killing more people than ever.
Depressed? Good.
Then my job here is done.
This has been
another Nightly Show
Super Depressing Deep Dive.
Sweet dreams.